well guys we weren't gonna initially
check this out but after many many
requests and the just perpetuating news
cycle we thought we would give our two
cents on this ezra miller body cam
footage there have been a couple of
these angles floating around that
apparently shed some new light on the
situation overall and maybe paint uh
ezra miller in a different light than
just the destructive one we've been
seeing them in lately don't know if this
includes the incident in which like a
chair was thrown at somebody i assume
not i don't really know how this would
go to justify that because this is a
multiple altercation
situation but either way curious to see
what kind of light this sheds on
everything we've heard so
[Music]
it's spit in far face okay come over
here come over here
i'm nuts right now why what happened
no nothing oh
i was just playing darts okay
and this guy right here which one the
one milestone honda is
his
i think one thing that is very important
to point out yeah remember stephen
colbert even tweeting about this as well
is that if you go to yelp on this
restaurant's website that there are a
lot of people who are talking about
being treated in a way that feels very
much like racism segregation yes we got
to keep that in mind as well when
watching this just that was a fair thing
to address
wait what what does he mean by films
himself for nft crypto i feel like
that's a sarcastic joke unless he's
really putting these things up on the
blockchain and having people buy them as
unique digital art
i'm sure someone would buy it but i also
feel like that's probably just a
sarcastic crack
come tell me your name on your back
come over here tell us what happened
what is your name what is your name
yeah what is your name
i cannot tell you my name
i just like know what happened
no this brother i was playing darts okay
and then why uh
my girly girl okay and he come right up
to me and just like
he started shouting no no no no
i don't go down okay so he's split in
your face
two
and i was like oh stop cause
yeah what's up
yeah okay i feel like he thought he was
somebody else
no i mean like he's not qualified
if you guys light him up i go to
lightning
but still i you know i forgot i know
that's disrespectful right right
uh
jesus and that is a pretty nasty threat
if you guys don't light him up i'm going
to light him up yeah that's that's a
regression if the guy is telling the
truth though about how he was just doing
his thing and then he was spit on while
he was doing his thing i could
understand someone verbally saying
something that aggressive i've been in
situations where people have threatened
my life before over the stupidest things
and so i could imagine something like
that it could be enough to get someone
to verbally say that not saying it's
okay i don't know it doesn't bode well
for this but individual i guess in this
particular moment but let's keep going
damn they got far
wait so was he
was that's her fleeing from the police
that's the sense i get yeah
especially if no one gave him a name or
a badge number central
central 131 i mean just i'm being
arrested for disorderly confidence yeah
okay i was assaulted
and playing all of this yeah
i'm sorry no you're not going to figure
it out
real quick
you like
half a mile
okay ezra just said that the guy in the
bar declared himself as a nazi and
attacked tactizer
i mean that that does change the
narrative around significantly if this
person is a self-declared nazi i guess
the reason why i wanted to point out the
things earlier because i heard that kind
of factors in to this story that as
we're saying under arrest with ezra
identifying i believe as jewish i can
imagine that as something where as would
feel the need to probably stand up
attack fight was ezra the one who
instigated
the fight themselves you know so that's
kind of like a big question at hand here
it's really hard to read the situation
because we're not here for any of it
yeah yeah it's just two people's words
and i mean if ezra if they were
assaulted then that's one thing you know
because it just changed who the provoker
is so i mean if that's the case then at
least for this isolated scenario you
could yeah understand i don't know it's
just their word against the other guy
what did i do wrong
a guy in that bar declared himself as a
nazi i have it on film and he attacked
me okay so i claim my ninth amendment
rights to not be
unlawfully persecuted for a crime of no
designation disorderly conduct being
something i am unguilty of i claim my
fourth amendment rights to not be
searched and seized on no probable cause
that you will not be able to offer in a
court of law
i claim my fourth amendment rights to
not be searched and seized
[Music]
without probable cause i claim my fourth
amendment rights to not be unlawful hey
you just touched my penis please don't
do that
i'm not gender non-binary i don't want
to be searched by a man i'm transgender
and i'm binary and i don't want to be
searched by a man i claim my fourth
amendment rights they're nerf guns just
in case you worry that they're bullets
those are nerf bullets thank you for
listening they're fake and they're a toy
thank you for listening my belt buckle
in my nerf bullet i appreciate that
laughing yeah
flash ring means a lot
look i'm not one to speak for
transgender although i believe everyone
in the trans community has equal rights
something about that felt like
weaponizing that identity at a certain
moment if that makes sense yeah
yeah i mean i don't know what he what i
don't know what they felt versus what is
there on camera obviously i'm not gonna
say that their experience is just flat
out wrong or whatever but but yeah i
mean at that moment in time it almost
feels like anything and everything i can
use at my disposal to get them to stop
which on the one hand i understand and
on the other hand i i don't know like
the situation is still
unclear enough to me that i can't quite
tell who's in the in the right
yeah yeah if that guy in the bar was a
nazi and actually you know started
something with ezra then then i
understand generally speaking i mean it
seems like they were also a little drunk
so that plays in i still think there's
at least two other incidents that have
not been explained who said yeah it
definitely needs some explanation
especially the most recent one for the
second arrest lunging a chair at
someone's head believe that person
needed like medical attention for that i
don't know how you can excuse that
especially breaking into someone's own
residence maybe they were nazis too i do
wonder if there was any particular
investigation into what miller is
claiming it's not uncommon for the media
to keep certain things out of the news
it only seemed fair that if we were
going to talk about the other things we
should probably at least address this
side of things as well regardless i
don't think this video makes ezra look
good at the same time i'm like you know
if i was in this situation
if i felt like this is i'm being
wrongfully accused and wrongfully
arrested for something i would react
probably the exact same way and probably
with the worst temper i can't fault that
if that is the case you know regardless
the footage does not look warm for the
flash actor we'll see what happens where
do you stand on this do you think this
helps ezra's argument do you think
hazard should still maintain the title
role of the flash moving forward leave
your thoughts down below we will talk
with you all soon